you got to start diving into those
things that you are afraid of you don't
gain confidence by going to the spot
that makes you feel good if it's hard to
be around people you're with the wrong
group of people the minute you begin to
get external in your life worrying about
what other people think about you right
you vote you've lost all control you and
it never fills you up wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
what's a belief nation is Evan I believe
in you and this channel is designed to
be a part of your daily success routine
so tailless is your best believe life
and learn five remarkably powerful ways
to boost your confidence also if you
want to know what day log demagogues and
others have to say about confidence as
excellence check out my 254 series where
everything to the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the links
to join are in the description below
after you practice Marshall you develop
this natural self confidence not
cockiness but you develop this natural
self confidence everything I didn't want
to do is what got me to where I'm at
today
[Music]
okay let's take it off with rule number
wanna face your obstacles with David
guidance how do I gain more confidence
it starts with yourself man you got to
start diving into those things that you
are afraid of you don't gain confidence
by going to the spot that makes you feel
good it could be a false reality in the
second life gives you that challenge all
you want to do is go back to what makes
you confidence or what gave you
confidence is that happy spot no what
gives you confidence what gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table trying to learn how to
read and write all my own realizing I
can't learn the way you learn I can't
but I can't learn but gives you
confidence not being afraid it's
overcoming the fear Isis stutter
severely bad so right now I don't know
how many people are gonna watch this no
it gives me confidence is knowing I'm no
longer care you know if I say or start
stuttering to you yeah that's what gives
me compass is facing these things over
coming up if they be not overcoming them
every day but facing them and face in
the face and pretty soon like there's no
one man this is where it's at hmm it's
not in that comfort zone it's in the
discomfort zone is where my confidence
is getting built mm-hmm that's where
it's getting built but people want to
they want to ease your answer yeah there
has to be an easier way it's not I'm
sorry I searched for it my entire life
rule number two getting good at what you
do with Dane Locke confidence I believe
is something that you need to develop
when I was young I had no confidence
when I first came to Canada I was the
invisible kid I was the kid that was
sitting in the very back of the
classroom I would never put on my hand
never ask any questions because because
I couldn't speak a word of English I
didn't ought to connect with people I
didn't ought to talk to people
so I had no confidence I would finish I
remember clearly I would faint had no
friends I was finished class I know with
my little little backpack on one look
look look on the floor I wouldn't make
make eye contacts with anybody because I
was afraid to connect with people and I
wouldn't talk to anybody I'll just go
home and every single day was like that
and I want to make sure I walk on this I
along the locker versus walk in the
center cuz I wanna I don't want to bump
into anybody and we're so afraid they're
people you would even want to ask me a
question I was so afraid of people so I
had no confidence confidence is
developed I know for a fact I'm a
walking breathing example of you can
develop confidence confident comes from
competence how could you get confident
confidence if you suck at everything
you're not good at anything you don't
have no skills you have no direction of
course you have no confidence very
simple and the problem is in your life
the people around you the role models
that you have the role model just the
people around in general think about the
people around parents relatives friends
how many of them have confidence not the
body types
not those motion how many of them truly
have inner self-confidence Camden
not many and those are people around you
so you learn from those people cause you
have no confidence but when you develop
their skills when you develop that
confidence when you're good at what you
do you feel good about what you do
you do more what you do and people tell
you that you're good of course guess
what then you get more and more
confidence and think of confidence like
oh that's a brick one brick at a time
not overnight but one brick at a time
you build that you build that and who
asked you even I'm a mistake I've never
lost money in business all this I build
it back up and we cover get gave me more
confidence you know what I could do this
once I could do that second time I could
do that a third time I know for a fact
that I didn't create it I didn't
accomplish my success by default I
created my success by design that gives
me confidence knock on wood I could lose
everything
morale I know that I could make
everything back and more not because the
money because of who I am that's
confidence you get good at what you do
you have confidence how could you not
have confidence when you're so good at
what you do rule number three be with
the right group of people with Mel
Robbins when I'm with cooler or popular
guys I feel inferior and worthless which
affects me and weirdly I try so hard to
impress them and be like them like a
chameleon I try to avoid them but I feel
left out whatever I do I feel sad or
useless what can I do in order to
overcome this you don't have to hang out
with people you don't like there's a pro
life tip for everybody you don't have to
one of the things that is a massive
indication that you're hanging out with
the wrong group of people is that you
don't feel comfortable being yourself
the second you try to be somebody else
or you feel like a chameleon just to fit
in you are trying to fit in with the
wrong group relationships only work when
you can be the real you people thrive on
energy that's what drives connection
you're with people that make you wither
and hide and feel insecure you are with
the wrong people if it's hard to be
around people you're with the wrong
group of people when relationships work
they work because they click and the
reason why they click is because you can
be the real you they don't make you feel
inferior you're making yourself feel
inferior by hanging out with people and
pretending you're not yourself so every
time you're hanging out with a group of
people and you act like a chameleon
you're actually invalidating yourself
because your own actions are telling you
you're not good enough to just be
yourself around these people so the only
way to deal with this is either show up
with that group of people and be your
full self and every time you think
something inferior just knock that
thought out of your mind say what you
really believe be interested in what
you're really interested in or the
easier route honestly dropped the
popular kids and find your people you
need to find your people and your people
are the kind of people that the second
you hang out with them you don't feel
like less of yourself you feel like more
of yourself you don't feel like you got
to hide or be somebody else you feel
like you want to express yourself and
show up and be more of yourself that's
the indication that you have found your
people
or keep the promises you made within my
land where does self confidence come
from right which is important because
there's no relationship between that and
eroding your self-confidence in other
words self confidence is really self
trust so the first thing is the people I
know that are really happy are very
self-aware in fact the best
entrepreneurs I know are very self-aware
they're aware of their shortcomings
right they want to improve them they
want to get to the next version of
themselves all the time and so for me
self confidence comes because I didn't
have it and I think anytime you meet
somebody like yourself or myself who
might now appear self confident it's
because I really had to find tools and
resources because I was so insecure and
shy and introverted
so I had to find techniques and
resources to build that up in me and for
me it's very simple it's the promises
that I keep to myself if I have a habit
over and over again to stack one on top
of the other of keeping promises I make
to me not other people in other words
the minute you begin to get external in
your life worrying about what other
people think about you right you've out
you've lost all control you and it and
it never fills you up and people's
admiration people's gratitude towards
you will never fill you up it's your own
it's your own inside and so for me
self-confidence comes from keeping the
promises I make to myself and the other
part of it is being aware I'm doing it
in other words most people don't give
themselves enough credit all the time
they're very aware of these 20 percent
things and not aware of the 80 right and
that's why the dosage is so important -
you've nailed it it should be 80/20
right because people get addicted to
this I'm not good at this people don't
like this about me I don't feel good
instead of focusing on the 80 and
stacking up wow I did eat what I said I
was going to today I did get up when I
said I was going to I made the amount of
phone calls I treated people in such a
way I promised myself it's not just
doing those things it's rewarding it's
being aware of it and stacking that up
and rule number five the last one before
very special bonus tip is go on a news
diet with Deen gracias what are the
things that dig in your confidence I
realized at an early early time has
probably been ten years that watching
the news for me when I watch the news
and I see that it looks like the
world is going to hell in a handbasket
or what the president is saying today or
what Congress is saying are you
listening to the left or the right or
there were people in the middle if you
listen to all the gun violence and all
like all the news does for me is make me
question where the world is going in my
next level so for ten years now I've
been on a news diet I don't watch the
news I have no clue what's going on nor
do I care it was the biggest
transformation in my life I where I want
to spend my time I would spend time with
my family the people I love my kids my
team members they deserve the best of me
they don't deserve Dean at 95%
confidence they deserve a hundred
percent and if I watch the news it
brings it down so I won't be the best
team leader I won't be the best father I
won't be the best man I can be I won't
be a best inspiration for you so screw
the news it Digg is my confidence it's
out I've been on a news diet I challenge
you to do the same thing now got a
special bonus cut from Robin Sharma and
how to flow with the seasons that I
think you're really gonna enjoy but
before that it's either the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
in your life or business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go
question number one what would a news
diet look like for you number two what
promises you make to yourself that you
would need to keep and number three what
kind of people do you need to start
being around and our week ourselves
think that success in life is being
happy happy happy always being in the
sunshine always being successful and
society has sold us a bill of goods that
if we're not successful and we're not on
our games and if we're not waking up
happy and if we're not full of joy and
if we're not feeling all this confidence
there is something that is wrong and we
deep love and respect this could be one
of the most important things I share
with you in this podcast that is just
your ego screaming and that's why I say
flow with the seasons a life beautifully
lived is a series of seasons a legendary
producer is not always at the top of the
mountain and so stop resisting I
encourage you
stop resisting the natural flow of epic
performance stop resisting the natural
seasons of life you see and so what
happens is when you stop struggling and
you learn again it's a muscle but you
just learn to relax with life and you
simply understand part of living a
legendary business life and part of
living a rare air personal life means
you're gonna have seasons of so-called
success in society maybe it's making a
lot of money being really productive
being at the top of your game
receiving the accolades of peers feeling
you are nailing your your your your
goals and your ambitions and your KPIs
or key performance indicators and you're
gonna have seasons where you're confused
seasons where you feel heartbroken these
seasons where you feel depleted seasons
where you are struggling and the more
you learn to relax into every season the
more you will generate this internal
power which I call confidence
if you want more on how to develop
confidence check out the one rule video
I made on it the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
confidence confidence confidence
confidence confidence confidence
confidence confidence